Sydney is best known for its iconic Opera House,...
...which is regarded as a marvel of modern architecture.
Designed in 1957 by Danish architect Jorn Utzon,...
...this landmark boasts sets of interlocking vaulted shells or sails...
...set upon a terrace platform and surrounded by pedestrian concourses.
Experts have argued that the design...
...was beyond the capabilities of engineering at the time,...
...and the complicated project took 14 years to complete in a series of three stages.
The Opera House was completed in 1973...
...and formally opened by Queen Elizabeth II in a televised ceremony.
During your visit to Sydney, you'll enjoy a visit to this world-famous landmark,...
...which was designated a UNESCO World Heritage Site in 2007.
With its concrete flying sails on the harbor,...
...the Sydney Opera House is surely one of the greatest architectural wonders of the world.